konna no tire coaches corner and that
Coach is Michigan head coach Jim
Harbaugh last game was Saturday win over
Florida 3317 next game will be Saturday
against the Cincinnati Bearcats attack
each day Harbaugh is a podcast at debuts
today you can hear it now every Tuesday
at podcast 1.com the new podcast one app
and Apple podcast it'll feature Jim Jack
his dad John Joni horrible the whole
family is there with the Harbaugh
podcast there so Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
with Jim Harbaugh but we're watching
that game with in fact I watched a
little bit of the rear last night and
then I saw spate with the second of his
to pick sixes there one was his fault
the other one I didn't think was then he
had the block punt so I was going oh boy
and you know Jim Harbaugh kept his
composure on the sidelines and coach
joins us now coach that let me get to
the important part first good morning
we're taking a guess on what you had for
breakfast today
ah cornflakes like fritzy clothes fritzy
had raisin bran I thought you weren't
even a breakfast guy like you just like
skipped it and you went right to lunch
that's that's that's the usual that is
the usual but it happened I went back
home and picked up the kids to go to
school and that's what they were having
so I enjoyed a baurel of cornflakes this
morning I like it but that's it that's
all I wanted to talk to you about just
find out what your 2% milk on their
cornflakes right no I don't want to get
Urban Meyer upset again all right now
let me ask you about this podcast do you
know how to download a podcast what do
you know about a podcast that it's
similar to a radio show it's uh and it
can be accessed to the Internet
whose idea was that idea I don't know
who came up with it first but
it was it was it was kind of thrown
around and the offer like you and your
dad should should do a podcast you guys
you guys these conversations you to have
I'm almost every day would be
interesting for people to hear and it
would be great to document your dad and
his stories and his perspectives on
things and then over the summer norm
Pettis who established Westwood one and
now does podcast one mmm
approached us with the idea and we said
yes so that's the
short and the long version of how we
started doing a podcast well you know
what I bet your dad but give people like
is there a favorite Jack hardball story
he's got a good one today that's on the
podcast and I heard you talking about
the interception for the touchdown the
interception for the test and then we
get a blocked punt I mean three straight
things occur and he always he likes it
he likens it to getting punched in the
nose you know getting sucker-punched and
and and what that feels like and then
you know what do you do when that
happens and you feel the blood you get
hit across the nose and the blood starts
to come out of the nose and go over the
upper lip and then around the corners of
your mouth and some of your some of the
blood goes in your mouth your taste in
your own blood at that point here you
see the blood drip down to the to the
ground and in the dirt it starts to form
little globs people are looking at
everybody's forms a circle around you
and everybody you know is it gasps with
their mouths open and they're wondering
what you're gonna do next and you and
you got two options at that point I mean
you can you can turn and walk away or
run away or you can you could fight back
and that's that's his analogy for what
happens in a football game you know
especially to a young team where do what
do they do when when it when it when it
goes bad and what's their reaction I
thought as he said our team react
well in that situation you know they
they they turned in wheeled and and
fought back and and ended up acquitting
themselves very well
I watched the re-air last night I tuned
in just as spate through the next pick
six and then there was the block punt I
was surprised at your composure and the
first thing I thought of is I'm watching
your demeanor on the sidelines is I
wonder if what you went through as a
quarterback when you were in the NFL
does that affect you at all in how you
coach quarterbacks does it yeah yeah
I've been in those situations where
where you've been you know you've been
punched in the nose or you're bombing
you know you just it's just it's going
bad and you're you're you're just out
there bombing for everybody to see and
and you got a you got a chance I mean
you got a chance as a as a player as a
team as a unit to get the train going in
the other direction me you just got to
come to a stop and you got to turn it on
the tracks and get it going the other
way and it's it's it's not easy to do
but it's the better way to than just
competing and in giving in so yeah that
that I've been have been there and and
you know kind of benefit you know enough
times to where I know complete
humiliation been humbled and you know so
your your hardened to it this does
yelling at a quarterback ever helped no
I haven't found it to ever yeah you know
I don't think so home because when did
kit would yell at you didn't help at all
we had a special relationship so you
know I knew him and you know I love Mike
Ditka and I understand I mean that's I
understand how important it was to him
and I knew he wanted the players to be
successful I knew he wanted me to be
successful I knew he didn't want me to
bomb
and you know just it was coming from a
place of he wanted the team to be
successful and be good I understood that
I understood it because I you know we've
been been together for five six seven
years so you know I had a great
understanding of where he was coming
from but yeah that's that's uh it if if
you can't here's another here's a really
another important thing to understand
that you know whether a football player
or even whether you're a quarterback if
you can't if you can't take criticism or
you can't take getting yelled at or you
know even you know make it a mistake and
not being able to recover from it then
you're not it's not the position to be
playing I mean that's you've got to have
you got to have thick skin or you're not
gonna you're not gonna survive as a
football player or as a quarterback I'm
AG owl I liken it to a golfer you know
you got a you get one in the water and
you know you got to be got to be able to
pull another ball out of your pocket
drop it down and then still be able to
shoot for the flag I mean that's what a
quarterback has to do he throws an
interception or two one two gets
returned for a touchdown to that gets
returned for the touchdown you've got to
be able to come back and still be
willing to fit the ball you know 25
yards downfield to a to an open receiver
and not have no conscious about what
what took place just a series before and
then wilt spate did that and yes that's
a talent because you'll see guys that
they just after something like that
happens they cannot even they can't even
think about throwing a 25 30 yard throw
downfield anymore because they they'll
don't protect against another
interception or another bad thing
happening and you realize for those guys
that's you're not in the right position
and so I was I was proud happy that you
know Wilton's got that in him you know
he's wired that way that you know he's
he doesn't crumble he doesn't fall apart
he he can he can stand up against it and
and come back and keep fire
for the flag and I hope that makes sense
but that's that's that's why my
experience has taught me and and it and
it's chosen Wilton and he's got that
ability to do that attack each day the
Harbaugh's podcast debuts today podcast
one app and apple podcast podcast 1.com
talking to a Jim Harbaugh content entire
Coaches Corner
your placekicker Quentin Norton for six
field goal attempts to from 50 yards or
longer you had a sleepover at his house
if you didn't have the sleepover at his
house when you're recruiting him do you
think you would have landed him oh yeah
yeah definitely need to do the sleepover
I it was just fun it was Quinn was a you
know quintessential Michigan guys from
Michigan great family he's uh I thought
he was gonna come to Michigan and that
was we get that at that stage I mean it
was it was just great to get to know him
and his family the teachers everybody
you know there was it was in it in
Quinn's life so you know 24 hours at 24
hours to do a home visit and wanted to
use every minute because I really liked
Quinn and thought he was a real talented
player and you know want to make sure
that that you get to know him and the
family as well as you possibly can so
yeah used every minute allotted 24 hours
that that we by rule could have and it
was it's good not only at that time when
you're getting a NOAA player but also
going forward because now I think people
feel more comfortable you know now Quinn
and Quinn's parents and I I mean we got
a great great relationship they feel
comfortable calling me because they know
me and I feel comfortable calling them
because because we know each other
better and you know that's that's hard
that's a big part of it you know being a
in a coach you know player the players
know the coach coach knows the players I
think it's really important yeah
have other recruits saying are you gonna
sleep over like how much do you really
want me coach well I mean we could keep
talking about the sleepover or I mean we
could talk about what's really really
important here is that Quinn Nordine set
a record Michigan's been playing
football for 138 years and for 138 years
is the first time a kicker has kicked
250 yard plus field goals in one game I
think that's remarkable I think that's a
you know really really unbelievably
remarkable in his first game kicking
field goals that he accomplished that so
that's really cool
and Quinn's wired he's that kind of guy
we've got to know him really well and ii
say about Quinn is he he likes he likes
the pressure moments he he visualizes
I'm he told me when when I was
recruiting him you know that you know
his is his dream his visit what he
visualized was was playing against our
biggest rival being on the right hash it
was a 43-yard field goal and he makes
the game-winning field goal and I always
thought that was kind of always stood
out to me in my mind the most of
anything any conversation I had with
Quinn and his family you know that that
he was thinking about that in high
school and he was he was thinking about
doing that for Michigan he told me that
well while we work rooting him that's
that stands out the most and then now
fast forward two years in his first ball
game and he makes four field goals two
of them 50-plus and and sets a record so
got to keep going now he's got to do it
the next now he's got to do it this week
and then the week after and the week
after that now that you've done it once
that's that's great but now you're doing
it the next time and and then the times
before don't even matter anymore so
but this yeah right now standing here
sitting here I'm thrilled for Quinn and
that he's a Michigan Wolverine that that
he accomplished that I'm very happy for
him the podcast attack each day the
Harbaugh podcast
with Jim and Jack and John and Joanie
and you can get it podcast one dot-com
and the podcast one app coach
congratulations on the wind thanks for
joining us and good luck with the
podcast
thank you very much dad okay take care
that's Jim Harbaugh then we'll talk
about those silly sleepovers he wants to
talk about his kicker actually kicking a
couple of field goals there I want to
talk about sleepovers and if I'm being
recruited by Harbaugh then I'm gonna go
use sleepover coach do you really want
me a kicker get to sleep yeah yeah forty
it's making me think of the recruiting
process of the four of us and who would
you most Continental Tire coaches corner
the official tire Major League Soccer
soccer fans expect peak performance on
the pitch also demand peak performance
on the street
that's why Continental has built a tire
for what you do can't say enough about
them proud supporter the Dan Patrick
show visit Continental Tire calm for
more the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience